cultural mining describes the process by
which the most valuable parts of culture
by which we understand the arts
humanities and philosophy are recovered
and made useful for our own times in
cultural mining the practical sides of
culture are carefully extracted and
cleaned blasted and reloaded and then
used to manufacture the mental tools
that we need to navigate contemporary
life it's been a historic problem that
hugely valuable cultural insights have
often been lodged within highly
unappealing material far below ground
it's been dark and cramped in the
corridors of culture and hardly anyone
other than certain accredited experts
have been tempted to visit the material
has been like metal in all entirely
impractical in its raw state for culture
to be useful to us it needs to go
through a process of refinement you have
to separate cultural insights from a lot
of surrounding material like in gold
mining only a very small portion of what
had originally been dug out will ever be
usable to make the finished precious
item that our society needs good ideas
it's around this process of refinement
that the big difference between the
school of life and standard universities
becomes apparent we're very grateful to
these universities for digging the mine
shafts and keeping open the ton
we have a different project we're
interested in the extraction and
utilization of the material on the
surface rather than its preservation and
interpretation below ground the idea of
cultural mining is new and still feels a
little weird but it has a critical role
to play in our world because at present
lots of people don't
sadly believe that culture has anything
much to offer them this isn't their
fault of course when you look at the raw
material form in which culture is
generally laid out for us no wonder most
people don't bother but that's a huge
pity we've started doing the mining deep
in the cultural ground to help us meet
the multiple confusions and anxieties of
our own times
you